When you sign with the Spurs,
your soul and your personality are put into the box.
There will be a new king in the East
It is your time
Spurs of the East
Your Grace?
You wanted to see me?
Yes
I like to pretend they’re…little eggs
You see, the lower houses,
they are the hens.
And I...
am the fox that snatches their little babies.
You’ve collected so many…
So much talent
almost, uh, too much
In Bostonia, there is no such thing as too much.
I know one thing
Lord Pop would have never lost control of this house
Pfft...Spurs of the East...
Lucky for you,
there’s one last road trip before the tournament starts.
I suggest you find a way
to get our knights on the same page.
Or else…
You would never. This city loves me.
Like they loved The King in the Fourth?
Get it done
Unbelievable we gotta share a tent with the rotation guys
We was the heroes last year!
If you’re feeling cramped, expand your mind
Squires these days...so entitled
Better stop calling us squires, Marcus
You don’t scare me, Terry
You think you’re some wise veteran—
What is that?
I’ve seen that before. That there is a Soul Box.
When you sign with House Spurs,
your soul and personality go into that box.
So it’s like a…Spurs culture thing?
I didn’t want it to come to this
but there is too much talent here in this room
for us to be treading water in the fourth seed.
The Soul Box will help us contain our emotions and our egos,
so that this group can reach its potential.
Also makes you dull as dirt
That thing's the reason nobody heard of me in San Antonio
Oh, yeah. That’s the reason.
I’ll do it
All right, Al
I want you to close your eyes and place your hand on the box
Ser Al Horford,
do you hereby commit fully,
to sacrifice your soul for the good of House Celtics?
Aye
So did it work or what?
He didn’t flinch!
All right, who’s next? Anyone?
I’ll do it
OK, no. Lucky—
Gimme that box. I’ll do it.
-Put my soul right in that box
-Thanks, Lucky, but this is for knights
Marcus the Smart?
I…I can’t. I’m sorry. My whole game is about emotion.
Jaylen?
Uh, I’m just worried about my brand is all
What about you, Kyrie?
Ha, subjugate the light of my soul to your rectangular prism?
No way...
I can’t even commit to next year
Wow...what a leader
OK, then why don’t you do it?
Well, I just...
don’t want to jeopardize my Mamba Mentality is all.
Yeah, gods forbid you stop shooting 20-footers
Oh, please. You’re one to talk.
-Oh, I’m Jayson Tatum. I’m the man.
-Very funny.
I’m going to House Pelicans to be the man!
All right, guys. Come on!
You know what? Clearly, this was a bad idea, OK?
You guys are obviously not the Spurs,
and I am clearly...not Lord Pop.
No...you’re not
You’re Brad Stevens.
The best X’s and O’s man I’ve ever known
Yeah, nobody can write out-of-timeout plays like you
Yeah, well, unfortunately,
there’s no timeout long enough for me to fix all of THIS team’s issues.
But what if there was
Who said that?
The Time Lord…
Wait, ‘Time Lord'? I thought that was just a nickname.
There’s a lot of things people don’t know about me
Don’t get enough minutes
Tell me about it
But I’m pretty versatile. I can rebound, I can block,
and I can stop time.
Where’d you learn how to do that?
Texas A&M
But you were only there for two years!
...or was I?
Whoa
So how does one just...stop time?
Just asking questions here
It's a magic potion…called So’Da
Banned in the realm since Jason Kidd used it against House Lakers,
late in a battle when he had no timeouts left.
Exactly how long are we talking about here?
It will last till either you've
come up with a way to solve our problems…
or 34 years...whichever comes first
Why 34?
It’s the Truth…
34 is the Truth’s number
The guy who’s worse than Dwyane Wade!
Actually, no. That’s just how much So'Da I have.
All right, you’ve got this, Lord Commander!
Yeah!
-You’re Brad Stevens!
-You’re a freaking genius!
-You're smartest in the realm!
We know you can do this, Lord Commander!
Are you all mad?
Do you really think he can just come up with some
magical out-of-timeout play that’s gonna fix all of our chemistry issues?
Yeah, you know what? I do.
Because I’m Brad F--king Stevens
Time Lord, ready when you are
All right
Time...
OUT
OH  F--K
Lord Commander?
You look like you’ve aged—
34 years. Yep.
So you...you didn’t...?
Nope
So, what’s all that?
Mostly just gibberish. I gave up 20 ago, actually.
What’s THAT?
All right,
I’ve got some good news and some bad news.
Bad news first
Lucky got frozen in time with me
The So'Da spilled on him
Oh, no. What have I—
Unfortunately for Lucky,
he swore a blood oath to always perform during timeouts,
obviously never thinking he’d, well...yeah.
But he kept performing. He was juggling. Dancing.
Doing those wacky dunks
Man, was he funny
By year two, he was mostly performing stuff that could be done from a chair,
like balancing bowls, singing, whatever.
It was around year three where...he stopped talking
He was just miming and deliriously flailing his arms
By year four, I thought he was doing this long bit
where he would just play dead.
By year five, I realized...
it wasn't a bit.
So, um...
what’s the good news?
Well, I came up with a few pretty clever inbound plays
that might get us to the second round.
So, if you subscribe to Bleacher Report,
you can get notified any time a new Game of Zones comes out.
And, can I comment, "first"?
Yes, anything
Even though I'm clearly not the first commenter?
Oh, whatever you want,
as long as you follow the community guidelines.
Wait! Stop! Stop!
He saw us! He saw us subscribing!